字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Masako Kigami
私は京都で この紋付きを
百年間染めてる会社の
荒川 徹と申します
今日は皆様に二つのご提案を
させていただきたいと思っています
その前に これ
武士で言う
脇差しの刀なんですね
皆さんに敬意を表すために
ここに置かしていただきます
それと ちょっと緊張してますので
転落防止のために
置かしていただきます
(笑)
画面を見ていただきますと
紋付き これですね
黒紋付きを染めております
着物産業 なかなか厳しい状態で
以前は ２兆円産業と
言われてたんですけども
現在では約４千億に 減少しております
その中で 我々は
今日 二つの提案をさせていただきます
一つは
着物の伝統的な技術を使って
アパレル製品を作るという提案
そして もう一つは
我々のこの黒染めという
技術を使って
洋服を再生して
アパレル産業を
エシカルな産業に変えていこう
という提案で御座います
簡単にまず紋付きの歴史を
ご紹介させていただきたいんですけども
10世紀にその起源は始まります
そして17世紀
武士の社会で略礼装として
こういった紋付きが
着用されるようになりました
そして明治32年
天皇陛下のお母様が
亡くなられた際に
国の法律によって
黒紋付き袴が
第一礼装として制定されました
その後 明治時代には
海外から洋服の文化が入ってくる
庶民も名字を使うようになりました
そして 名字を使えるようになってから
この ここに付いてます
家紋ですね
家紋をそれぞれのご家庭に
持たれるようになりました
そして 現在においては
どういった形で この紋付きを
着ておられるかと言いますと
例えば 結婚式
結婚式の時に男性が紋付き袴
そして お葬式の時に喪服
そして 画面上では
祇園の芸子さん、舞妓さんの
「事始め」という行事が京都でございます
その事始めの行事の時に
裾に模様のある あでやかな着物を
お召しになっております
こういったことが
着物の歴史でございます
ピークでは約 年間に
２百万反(たん)製造されてました
それが現在では
約50分の１の
４万反に減少しております
これは この紋付きだけやなしに
日本の伝統産業
全てで言われてることで
我々はこの伝統産業を
日本の素晴らしい技術を
いかに世界に広めるか
そして いかに
後世に残していくかということで
技術と新しいデザインを融合さして
次なる世代に向かって
技術を残していこうと考えております
こういった現場の写真なんですけども
職人さん 細かな仕事をしております
こういった職人さんが
どんどんどんどん減少しております
我々もおじいさんの時代から
私もおじいさんの時代から
商売しておりまして
おじいさんが現場で
手の爪の間が
染料で真っ黒やたんですね
そんなんを覚えてます
また ちょっとこれ
背中を振り返りますけども
見ていただきますと
右と左 全然色目が違います
我々の技術はこれが普通
これ失敗じゃないんですね
これが普通の染め
こちらが真っ黒に染める技術ですと
この技術を活用して
黒を極めていきたい
ということで提案をしております
京都では着物屋さん
不思議なモノで
まず 柄を染める着物屋さん
そして無地を染める
染め屋さんに分かれます
その中で無地は黒と色に分かれます
我々は約百年間
黒を専門に黒を極めてきて
それが我々の今の技術の
根底に御座います
そして 私が父の後を継いで
継ぐきっかけとなりましたのは
私は大学を卒業して
まず最初にプリント基板の
メーカーに勤めました
偶然にそのプリント基板の
メーカーの社長が
わしが会社行って朝ですね
社長が来られて
私は営業だったんですけども
ふと父の名刺を私に
渡されるんですね
実は昨日のパーティーで
君のお父さんとおうたよ と
名刺交換したんや
と言って父の名刺を出されました
その時に父の名刺を見ると
「二代目 御黒染司」
という肩書きが書いてございまして
その名詞を見た時に 自分の中で
私も家業というものをよく考えて
ふと 色んなことを振り返って
それから その夏に
その会社を退社して家業を継ぎました
継いだ後も着物業界は特に
紋付き業界は
どんどんどんどん斜陽で
需要が低迷してまいります
その中で なんとか
この技術を後世に残していけないかな
なんとか業界を 形を変えてでもいいから
残していかなあかん
という思いに駆られた矢先に
アパレルの小売業者から
コラボレーションの提案が御座いました
その時に我々の黒という技術を使って
色々とアパレルの製品を作りたい
というご要望が御座いました
それをきっかけに我々は
今持っている技術を使って
形を変えて後世に残していこう
ということで動き始めました
画面に御座いますように
シューズメーカーとコラボをして
色んな商品を作り上げました
また きっかけがあったんですけども
弊社のホームページから
ある女性が応募をしてきて
弊社のコンテンツにすごく興味を持って
すごく熱いメールやったんですね
ただ単に採用のメールを出すと 通常は
軽い気持ちが多いんですけども
我々の持っているコンテンツを
よくよく研究して
それを磨きたい
というような内容でありました
彼女は岡山の方で
有名なデニムメーカーの
デザインと企画をしておりました
彼女が入ってから
我々の技術を外から見た目で
どのように磨いていったらいいか
ということを
身体で段々段々
分かるようになりました
そして 色んなデニムであったり
セーターであったり
トートバッグであったり
色んな商品を作り始めました
そこで核となったのが
先程見ていただきましたけど
我々の技術 右と左の違い
黒さの違いです
これは我々黒染めという業界は
黒さの違いなんですけども
着物業界では色々な技法が御座います
例えばこれは絞り、友禅
ぼかし、型染め ですね
我々は自社の黒染めだけやなしに
着物の加工技術を使って
色んな製品を開発したいということで
今 手書きのTシャツであったり
お菓子と型染めを用いたり
そういった着物のデザイン、技術
アパレルのデザインを用いて
今 色んな技術を開発しております
その中でアパレルの
有名なブランドなんですが
こちらも弊社の黒に対して
興味を持っていただいて
黒を極めるということで
今展開しております
最終的には我々はやはり
着物の技術を残したいという思いで
色々展開しております
一つ目の提案は
着物の技術をアパレルに活かして
着物の伝統産業を守っていくこと
二つ目のご提案は
今 衣類で年間
約２百万トン以上が
日本で廃棄されてると言われています
リサイクル率を申し上げますと
空き缶とかペットボトルよりも低く
十数パーセントです
また 皆さんのご自宅の
タンスの中の衣類を
思い出していただくと
多分 半分以上が
お召しになっていない衣類
これはある自治体の
古着を集めた倉庫なんですけど
山のように古着が積まれてます
こういった衣類は
環境に対してものすごく
負荷がかかってます
今 世界で言われてるのは
地球一個分の生産に対して
1.5個分の消費をされてる
と言われます
そこで我々は昨年の10月に
WWF JAPAN とコラボレーションを行いました
このコラボレーションは
どういった企画かと申しますと
古着を黒く染めて
再生しましょうよ
という企画で御座います
今 我々は
皆さんのお手持ちの古着を染め変えて
再生しようというプランを
実行しております
今 彼女が着ている
洋服なんですけども
元は画面上の
ああいった衣類で御座います
それを黒く染め直すことによって
再生しています
これ不思議なんですけども
胸元の刺しゅうは
元の色が残って御座います
何故かといいますと
化学繊維なので染まらないんですね
我々の加工は
天然繊維を染めるという
加工で御座います
化学繊維は染まりません
ありがとうございます
次の男性も 同じように
元々はああいった衣類で御座いました
ここの赤い柄
ここにボーダーのラインがあるんですけども
このボーダーの部分は
プリントがされてまして
その部分 ちょっと手を挙げていただいて
見ていただきますと
この部分が
まだ色が残って御座います
というように
あ ここの縫製糸もです
縫製の糸もそうですね
これは天然繊維でなしに
ポリを使って縫製されてるので
このように残ってると
このコーデュロイのパンツなんかも
横のステッチが
縫製の糸がそのまま残ってる と
元々 シミがあったり
汚れがあったりした衣類で御座います
ありがとうございます
次に彼女が着ている衣類なんですけど
これも同じく白く
ちょっと画面では見にくいんですが
全体にすごく黄ばみが御座いました
その黄ばみを黒く染めて消しています
ボタンのところなんかは
これ 貝殻を使っておられますんで
貝殻の部分は染まらずに
残ってる ということで御座います
ありがとうございます
次の男性が着てる衣類なんですけど
これも画面上
見ていただいたら分かりますように
下は真っ黒に染まってます
上はボーダーが出てますし
例えばここのステッチですね
これも そのまま
染まらずに残っております
ありがとうございます
次に このコートは
すごく表情が面白いんですけども
綿とポリの混紡で御座います
ここでは[分かりませんが]
太陽の下に行くと 玉虫色に見えます
黒とポリが交互に編まれていて
それがポリの部分は染まらずに
黒の部分だけが染まっていると
そして このボタンホールの
ステッチなんかも
ポリの繊維を使っておられますんで
染まってない という
全く新しい衣類として
蘇るということで御座います
我々は 今 この技術を使って
一つは皆さんがお持ちの
古着を染め直して
新しい衣類として再生しよう
ということで御座います
このプランは 一つは
ハードは染め変えるというハードですけども
それに対して
色々とソフトウェアを組み込んで
提案してます
今 アパレルのデザイナーに
提案していますのは
デザインをする時から 初めから
染め直すという企画を頭に入れて
加工を施しておこうよ
糸使いをしましょうよ と
そして 消費者がお召しになった衣類を
再度染め変えることによって
二回使えるという
新しいデザインの考え方
これを広めていきたいと思っています
最後に 私から申し上げたいのは
まずは 今日のプランは二つ御座います
伝統技術を保全して
新しいデザインをする
それと黒く染めるという技術を用いて
衣類を再生する
今回 こういうプレゼンを
さしていただいて
私が常に思ってることは
自社の持っている
私自身が持っている
コンテンツ 技術に対して
思いを持って
熱い思いを持って
それを深く探求していく
そして そこに夢とビジョンを持てば
色んな人の力をいただいて
それが広がっていきます
TED のこういう場を
我々一介の職人が
喋らせていただくことも
すごい機会ですし
ただ私はその事業を通じて
いつも心に思ってるのは
誰にも負けない熱い心を持って
自分が信じる道に歩んでいく と
夢を持って 伝統産業を守って
次の展開をしたいと考えております
どうもありがとうございました
(拍手)